mais d'abord quel costume emmanuel
macron justement va-t-il en eau douce et
demain celui du chef de l'état celui du
candidat sans doute un peu des deux
c'est le lot de cette campagne qui
démarre le président veut bâtir les
champions de demain dans le domaine du
numérique de l'industrie vers des
biotechnologies ou de l'agriculture ce
plan d'investissement intitulé france
2030 pour être aussi posé les bases de
sa campagne économique samia déchire
après la relance l'investissement
le plan france 2030 c'est une enveloppe
de plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros pour réindustrialiser la france
son montant sera dévoilé demain par
emmanuel macron qui en avait fait la
promesse cet été à la rentrée après le
travail et les consultations en cours
nous déciderons d'un plan
d'investissement qui visera un objectif
bâtir la france de 2030 et faire émerger
dans notre pays et en europe les
champions de demain des champions
capables de rivaliser avec les géants
asiatiques et américains au plus fort de
la crise du coc vite 19 la fermeture des
frontières a jeté une lumière crue sur
la dépendance de la france à l'étranger
pour la production de certains matériaux
et composants le gouvernement veut re
localiser la production avec un objectif
nous permettent d'être indépendant sur
les technologies clés du 21e siècle
l'hydrogène vers l'intelligence
artificielle l'espace ou le semi
conducteurs le plan france 2030 doit
permettre de financer les projets des
jeunes startups françaises mais aussi
ceux des leaders industriels comme
l'avion bas carbone ou les futures
centrales nucléaires à échelle réduite
france 2030 un parfum de campagne lors
d'ébats tout de suite et je vous
présente mes invités isabelle veyrat
masson bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
historienne directrice de recherche au
cnrs spécialiste de communication
politique françois ecalle bonsoir soit
ancien rapporteur général de la cour des
comptes fondateur du site d'information
sur les finances publiques fip
echos.fr raphaël legendre bonsoir sans
thomas vous aussi vous êtes journaliste
à l'opinion votre titre à la une
aujourd'hui c'est france 2030 entre de
gaulle musk il faut choisir vous nous en
direz un mot tout à l'heure évidemment
et puis matthieu croissandeau bonsoir
mathieu est politique sur ce plateau
tous les lundis et mercredis feuillet là
tous les jours faux pas s'il faut pas se
tromper le mardi le jeudi c'est laetitia
cru pas alors je voudrais qu'on commence
par une petite analyse plutôt
communication sur ce qu'il va se passer
demain sous les dorures de délit de
l'elysée ça va se passer dans la salle
des fêtes devant des chefs d'entreprise
étudiants d'écoles d'ingénieurs une
dizaine de deux ministres on est dans le
classique de la communication
présidentielle raphaël legendre
c'est quoi ces il vous est maintenant
que ce soit à la hauteur de l'ambition
qui va essayer d'affiché avec ce avec ce
plan disons que ce plan c'est un
exercice un peu imposé à chacun des
présidents de la république il existe
depuis nicolas sarkozy qui souvenez vous
du rapport juppé rocard avait lancé les
programmes d'investissements dix ans
après on en est au numéro 4 et peut-être
bientôt le numéro cinq en réalité ce
futur plan donc sur le fond ça va être
quelque chose d'assez classique mais par
contre c'est un objet politique avec
lequel on peut faire beaucoup de choses
comme l'indiqué vous le rappeler
gentiment une de l'opinion aujourd'hui
on pourra faire en même temps du de
gaulle et en même temps du deuil mais
alors là sous le salon doré l'elysée ça
sera un peu la séquence de gaulle c'est
à dire le chef de l'état qui annonce
mettre des moyens importants pour
préparer la france de 2030 sauf que sauf
que c'est probablement pas une
commission administrative milan à
ministère qu'on va pouvoir trouver les
futures pépites de demain ça les halos
de meuse qui devront venir plus tôt
auprès de ces commissions pour présenter
des projets et ses deux deviendra
l'innovation dont un peu évidemment on
en est on y reviendra isabelle veyrat
masson l'exercice il est classique d'un
président de la république en année de
réélection fin de potentiel à l'élection
parce que si on fait la liste de ceux
qui ont essayé de s'y sont prêtés à
l'exercice match on l'a déjà fait sur ce
plateau et finalement il n'y a pas
beaucoup de deux précédents positif
c'est du classique pour vous alors ce
qui est du classique face qui est depuis
quelques années un classique c'est
effectivement plus en investissement il
y en a eu plusieurs et à chaque fois ils
sont salués ils sont annoncées une
manière assez grande ici mais ça l'a
évidemment ce qui est différent c'est
qu'on est en année électorale et surtout
qu'on a le sentiment qu'il ya une
répétition dans l'ouverture du carnet de
chèques et que les milliards valls
depuis que emmanuel macron était là et
comme il a quand même succédé à des
gouvernements qui était plutôt dans il
faut faire attention on est tenu par
trois pour cent
il faut à chaque fois qu'il y avait une
dépense on exigeait que la personne en
face nous explique comment il allait
trouver l'argent là depuis quelques
années on dépense on n'a pas le
sentiment qu'il ya une contrepartie
aucune explication au niveau des
recettes donc qu'est-ce que ça signifie
- ce qui m'amuse c'est que je me demande
si ça va pas pas avoir un effet
contre-productif c'est à dire que
normalement on ouvre ce cas d'échec
parce qu'on a le sentiment que les gens
vont être contents de recevoir quelques
chèques et là à force de distribuer un
argent sans véritablement le justifier
est ce que ça ne risque pas de faire
l'effet inverse c'est à dire non
seulement pour les gens à droite disons
le sentiment que finalement c'est pas
très sérieux oui on a un manque de
rigueur budgétaire à gauche pour ceux
qui sont pas très favorables emmanuel
macron personne n'y croit c'est affreux
les gens disent on va on va on va nous
rendre de l'argent on va nous si on nous
donne de l'argent on va devoir le
récupérer augmentation des impôts
augmentation des charges figues et ses
rangs et donc il ya une méfiance qui se
créent et donc finalement il ya quelque
chose là de deux contres qu'il risque
d'être contre-productive il faut qu'un
président de la république en campagne
et après une grande crise comme ça
répond ouvre son chéquier et face grâce
et distribue de l'argent et en même
temps be armand pour la première fois
j'ai le sentiment que ça peut se
retourner contre lui et c'est assez
étrange en même temps est-ce qu'il a le
choix
tout comme matthieu croissandeau demain
il ya le début de la promotion d'un
livre qui est très attendu le livre de
journaliste du monde gérard davet et
fabrice lhomme le titre c'est le traître
et launay en a priori quand on allume
t-il france dit ça doit pas être très
favorable emmanuel macron il commence la
locomotion le livre sort mercredi ça
risque est ce que c'est un peu court
circuite court circuiter pardon là le
voilà les annonces qui seront faites
demain d'après vous battez pour ce qui
est d'en mais alors faut se souvenir que
le 12 octobre 2016 les cinq ans les
mêmes d'avé et l'homme avait sorti un
livre qui s'appelait un président doré
pas des risques et qui avait achevé de
torpiller un françois hollande qui était
déjà très abîmée par son quinquennat
mais en gros ça l'avait empêché de se
représenter parce que ce qu'on y
trouvait c'était surtout des confidences
de françois hollande qui était très
surprenante et qui avaient misé à mal
l'image du chef de l'état de ce que je
sais de ce que je comprend l'exercice
est un peu différent cette fois-ci parce
qu'il n'ya pas de confidences des dames
mâcon il ainsi
donc après il ya une enquête on verra
c'est la charge ou à décharge avec des
gens qui qui reproche emmanuel macron de
façon circonstanciée ou non avec preuves
à l'appui ou non plein de choses mais
mais je pense pas qu'on soit du tout
dans le temps de même dans le même
exercice parce que ce qu'ils avaient
vraiment frapper l'opinion s'est enfin
françois hollande était prise en la
république et il passait ses soirées à
manger des patchs et de l homme en train
de commenter l'actualité qu'il n'ait
lui-même en train de vivre et de faire
donc c'est ça qui était qu'avait en gros
vraiment abîmé la stature du chef de
l'état bon allez on sort de la stature
qui est déjà
allé on va parler passés au fond et à la
question de la dette françois ecalle on
parle d'eux alors je sais pas 30 à 50
milliards d'euros il ya différents
chiffres sur ce qui sera annoncé demain
qui s'ajoute il avait ramasse on
l'évoquait aux centaines de mini arc ont
déjà été dépensés pendant la crise qu
vide
pour le payer des tests pour soutenir
l'emploi pour soutenir le travail
partiel etc la france doit j'ai lu ce
chiffre aujourd'hui déjà 144 milliards
d'euros à la banque centrale européenne
est ce que ça vous inquiète finalement
ce climat général est ce qui sera
annoncé demain alors ce ces annonces de
grands plans d'investissement répondre
quand même à une recommandation qui est
très fréquente chez les économistes qui
consiste à dire il faut dépenser
beaucoup plus pour investir parce que
c'est rentable pour l'avenir ça permet
d'augmenter le potentiel de croissance
et donc ça peut permettre de résoudre
ses problèmes d'endettement si vous avez
plus de croissance vous avez moins de
déficit et donc vous arriver arrêtez
arrêtez d'endettement et donc beaucoup
d'économistes dix ans le problème c'est
que on peut pas dire qu'il ya d'un côté
les dépenses d'investissement qui sont
toujours utiles et nécessaires et puis
d'un autre côté des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui sont mauvaises sur
lequel l'a au contraire il faudrait à
partir de peut-être l'année prochaine
serrer la vis pour en effet réduire
l'endettement public en réalité vous
avez dépenses d'investissement qui ne
servent strictement à rien et vous avez
vous pouvez construire des aéroports où
personne ne va s'est des dépenses
d'investissement et vous avez des
dépenses de fonctionnement par exemple
en formation la formation c'est du
fonctionnement ça peut être tout aussi
utile pour l'avenir donc cette
distinction enfin moi je considère
qu'elle est mauvaise et elle conduit à
sacraliser à dire il faut faire plus
d'investissements et donc à des chiffres
magiques du type on va faire 30
milliards d'euros 50 milliards d'euros
de plus d'investissements alors que le
fond du problème c'est de faire des
investissements intelligents rentable et
efficace et ça le problème en france
c'est qu'on n'en fait pas forcément
beaucoup on n'évalue pas toujours les
investissements et quand on les évalue
et qu'on trouve que finalement ils sont
pas à 13,6 intéressant mais il arrive
très souvent malheureusement que le
politique néfaste quand même parce que
le politique aime bien couper des rubans
inauguré dès des nouvelles autoroutes ou
des nouveaux projets d'affaires vieira
grande vitesse donc je ne sais pas ce
qu'on va nous présenter demain si ce
seront des investissements pertinents
verra mais j'ai un doute déjà la france
investit beaucoup les investissements
publics en france on est en pourcentage
du pipe on est au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne est au dessus de la plupart
des grands pays européens donc faut-il
en faire plus je ne sais pas je verrai
demain
mais ça c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est un peu ça fait les gens ce qu a
préempté entre guillemets emmanuel
macron dans cette campagne par rapport
parce que on peut dire c'est la compagne
de l'argent magique tous les candidats
effectivement il ya plus le verrou de
bruxelles donc tous les candidats ils
vont de leurs promesses mais emad
mcqueen a vraiment il préempte et ça moi
ce que je fais c'est sont des
investissements ne sont pas des dépenses
est pas ça va pas dans un puits sans
fond oui alors ça c'est pour plaire à
l'électorat de droite parce que en même
temps les dépenses courantes augmenter
l'année prochaine de 30 milliards
d'euros après déjà avoir explosé cette
année donc le crois qu'ils ont cote de
quoi qu'il en coûte pardon fonctionne
aussi sur des dépenses pas forcément
très productive à chaque fois par contre
c'est vrai que ses dépenses
d'investissement sont importantes pour
préparer l'avenir est là où je
nuancerais moi un peu le propos de
françois ecalle c'est que sur
l'innovation si c'est vrai qu'on dépense
beaucoup de manière globale sur
l'innovation on est un peu en arrière de
la main par rapport à quelques voisins
européens et surtout beaucoup plus par
rapport aux états unis c'est vrai que
l'enjeu il est peut-être plus européen
entre la chine et les etats unis
aujourd'hui que uniquement ce qu'on va
faire en france mais qu'est ce qu'a
révélé la crise ces 18 derniers mois
c'est qu'on pouvait avoir des vrais
problèmes de pénurie sur des matériaux
très important que ce soit les intrants
termes sanitaires sur des médicaments
aussi bête que de l'aspirine ou surtout
les semi conducteurs des semi
conducteurs qui ont envahi notre vie
aujourd'hui que vous trouvez de votre
voiture jusqu'à votre cafetière et ses
semi conducteurs sont produits à 70% par
une entreprise qui est à taïwan cette
entreprise a annoncé il ya quelques mois
qu'elle est qu'elle allait investir 100
milliards de dollars pour augmenter ses
capacités de production uniquement sur
les semi conducteurs donc nous on va
être là entre 30 et 50 milliards d'euros
est effectivement sur cinq à dix ans on
ne sait pas encore mais on voit qu'on
est quand même encore un peu court donc
il faudra pas attendre non plus une
transformation majeure de de ceux de ce
plan d'investissement et pour
l'innovation
d'autant plus que d'autant plus que
emmanuel macron aime faire un peu de
prestidigitation financière avec ses
grands plans tout le monde l'a oublié
mais en début de quinquennat on a déjà
eu un grand plan d'investissements de 57
à l'époque avait été montée par jean
pisani ferry dans ses 57 milliards
d'euros aviez un peu moins de 20
milliards d'euros d'argent nouveau en
fait on a recyclé énormément de choses
qui existait déjà là sur ce plan
d'investissement ça va être le cas aussi
on ne sait pas combien il y aura de
crédits nouveaux certainement pas 30
milliards parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment
les fonds on parle maintenant de 30 à 50
milliards d'euros peut-être que ces 20
milliards de dette c'est ce qui reste
investir des anciens programme
d'investissements d'avenir cet été on a
eu un programme d'investissements sur
les médicaments et sur l'innovation de 6
à 7 milliards qui pourraient être
recyclés aussi dans ceux dans ce grand
programme donc attendons de voir les
chiffres demain pour voir quelle en est
la vraie consistance alors ça permettra
peut-être de combler certains trous dans
la raquette que qu'il y avait eu lors de
la présentation du budget de l'année
prochaine on va accueillir mario vigreux
sur ce plateau bon soir marion puisque
pierre moscovici le premier président de
la cour des comptes qui étaient devant
les sénateurs tel 22 septembre
dernier
avait pointé le niveau d'endettement
effectivement les inconnus et le il n'y
avait pas eu l'aval donné par le haut
conseil des finances publiques
effectivement et ce au conseil de
finances publiques c'est en quelque
sorte la vigie 1 en matière de finances
publiques et vous l'avez dit son
président a donc été auditionnés et sur
la question du budget 2022 eh bien il
était il a expliqué qu'il était
incapable d'en donner une appréciation
car justement de nombreux éléments
étaient absents et par mieux justement
ce plan d'investissement écouter de a
suivi pour 2022 le haut conseil a été
saisi sur une base incomplète s'agissant
des dépenses qui ne contiennent pas
certaines mesures importantes que le
gouvernement souhaite voir adopter par
un moment
faute d'information sur le chiffrage de
ces mesures manquantes le haut conseil
ne peut pas à ce stade se prononcer sur
le caractère plausible ou non du sol de
public tall qui les saisit au titre du
plf 2022 et pierre moscovici précise
donc une nouvelle saisine du haut
conseil sera nécessaire une fois que ces
éléments auront été communiquées et puis
intégré par le gouvernement cette année
2022 est en tout cas présenté comme une
année de sortie crise de retour à la
normale dans le quotidien mais pour
pierre moscovici en matière de finances
publiques rien ne sera plus comme avant
car depuis 2019 le poids des dépenses
publiques est en hausse de deux points
et la dette a progressé de 10,7 fois par
rapport à à 2019 et face à cet
endettement public accru le président du
haut conseil appelle à la prudence
écoutez le à nouveau la sortie de crise
meilleurs que prévu le caractère
particulier y compris sur le plan
politique d'un 2022 ne doit pas masquer
que nos finances publiques sorte de la
crise marqué par un niveau d'endettement
inédit depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
et des dynamiques différentes en
recettes et en dépenses et que tout ceci
appelle la plus grande vigilance la
soutenabilité nos finances publiques
doit être activement des pendus défendu
y compris monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
par une rénovation et une modernisation
de notre système de gouvernance de nos
finances publiques il regrette
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement ait
refusé que le haut conseil rédige un
rapport sur la soutenabilité
la dette comme il en existait dans
certains pays européens l argument du
gouvernement étant de dire qu'un tel
rapport allait générer de l'inquiétude
mais justement pour les économistes ce
qui peut inquiéter les marchés ce n'est
pas un débat sur l'état de la dette et
son évolution mais c'est justement
l'absence de débat merci beaucoup marion
figure isabelle veyrat masson ce thème
de la dette il est finalement assez peu
présent dans la campagne qui démarre
sauf peut-être à droite n'a entendu
finir gorge et encore oui si valérie
pécresse ou xavier bertrand ont brandi
cet argument oui alors évidemment la la
pré campagne qui a débuté étaient très
éloignés de ces questions là puisqu'on
le sait est un candidat qui ait enfin
pris elle a aussi un prix candidat dans
une précampagne exe moore était arrivé
avec des thèmes imposant des thèmes qui
sont très très loin ces questions de
dette de finance de boire d'achat etc ce
terrain mais il y a une sale manie un
retour à la raison en reparlant de ces
questions budgétaires et financières
puisque lorsqu'on interroge les français
la première question qu'ils appellent le
premier thème qu'ils attaquent bien
avant l'immigration c'est la question de
pouvoir la chasse et la question de
l'emploi donc voilà il faut raison
garder et le fait que le président de la
vie qui pour des raisons d'ailleurs
conjoncturel puisque c'est le moment où
on présente le budget aborde ces
questions c'est évidemment extrêmement
positif mais enfin positif je pense que
ça fait ça change et les thèmes et
surtout ça va dans les thèmes qui
l'intéressent lui sur lequel il est
performant on peut imaginer que valérie
pécresse xavier bertrand et les autres
candidats de droite auraient pu se
saisir de deux cela pourrait
effectivement le faire ils l'ont fait il
ya eu quelques blagues assez drôle
puisque valérie pécresse a expliqué
qu'il fallait cra et que le président
est que quoi qu'il en coûte de quoi
qu'il en coûte pour mâcon c'est plutôt
quoi qu'il en coûte pour sa réélection
selon xavier bertrand donc c'est assez
drôle mais peut-être et on aurait pu
imaginer que dans un autre temps il
aurait pu prendre le cheval qui est allé
dans ce sens là ils ne font assez peu
parce qu'encore une fois le fait que
emmanuel macron a lâché à brides dans
tous les sens et que les français ont
plutôt sentiment que c'est normal que
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire parce
qu'il ya eu la crise et gilet jaune
parce qu'il ya eu la crise la crise de
france etc ascione activités chacun voit
bien qu'il ya eu un problème et donc
j'ai certes manière parler de parler de
vin critiqué la dette critiqué le quoi
qu'il en coûte
appelée à la l'austérité à la décence ça
ne marche pas ce n'est pas l'air du
temps et ils sont un peu piégé par ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est un plan
financé sauf pour edouard fine afin de
finalement ça a été là c'est l'un de ses
marqueurs oui de la création de son parc
de l'ordre dans les présentes il se
présente
la nature ayant horreur du vide il prend
cet espace qui a marché politique à
prendre est clairement aujourd'hui plus
personne ne parle de rigueur budgétaire
et pourtant des comptes bien tenues
c'est l'avenir d'un c'est l'assurance
d'un avenir plus commun
c'est quelque chose qu'on semble
complètement avoir oublié dans le quoi
qu'il en coûte qui a des effets de bord
qui ont débordé très au delà de du
gouvernement françois droite où
traditionnellement on était un peu les
tenants de la rigueur
ou même à gauche
certains vente et 7,7 rigueur en tout
cas un peu de sérieux budgétaire ça a
complètement explosé
et vous soulignez tout à l'heure ça
pourra effectivement créer une forme de
crainte chez le contribuable qui sait
bien qu'un jour ces dettes doivent être
remboursés et que donc les dépenses
d'aujourd'hui sont aussi les impôts de
demain pierre mosca pardon bruno le
maire ne cesse de répéter que cette
dette sera remboursée par la croissance
qu'il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
d'impôts comme on l'a vu après la
précédente crise qui avait cassé la
reprise et c'est vrai fait beaucoup de
mal à l'emploi en france il n'empêche
que la croissance ne suffira pas il faut
être très clair et que donc à un moment
soit on va devoir couper dans des
dépenses soit on va devoir augmenter la
pression fiscale pression fiscale qui
est en france une des plus élevées au
monde donc ce sera quand même très
difficile sur un corps social assez
irrité par les hausses d'impôts mathieu
pour présenter alors ça s'appelle france
2030 présenter un plan à dix ans et
c'est voir loin en politique quand même
alors on voit loin c'est la mode on
vient d'en parler qui pour faire bien il
faut voir loin at il clamé ce week-end
en lançant son mouvement baptisé horizon
parce qu'on voit bien l'idée importe
regard au delà du présent pour penser
l'avenir en même temps à nos horizons
c'est un point qu'on n'atteint jamais
c'est à peu près ça
horizon alors emmanuel macron qui est
mal écrit l'album maître des horloges dû
apprécier parce que lui aussi se
voudrait un homme du temps long et
retrouvée ce travail prendra dix ans il
faut le commencer dès à présent ça c'est
ce qu'il écrivait en 2016 dans son livre
programme révolution est pourtant à
mâcon c'est un président aussi
schizophrène parce qu'ils se réveillent
en capitaine au long cours du paquebot
france à penser le temps long et à la
moins de tempête il descend sur le pont
comme un simple matelot oui c'est pas le
seul non non c'est vrai françois
hollande ou nicolas sarkozy avait été
confrontée au même syndrôme en fait il
serait fille est toujours une part de
fantasme chez ces présidents qui se rêve
comme des présidents qui marquerait
l'histoire de l'abbaye un peu à la façon
dont dont on fait de gaulle et pompidou
oui ça se sache se passeront leurs
gardes après enfin ça se voit après
parce que l'époque de de gaulle pompidou
on disait c'est les grands travaux c'est
le concorde le tgv l'ordinateur mais je
dis c'est un fantasme parce qu'en fait
gouverner c'est choisir et
qu'aujourd'hui les arbitrages et
privilégie toujours le temps court sur
le tendon pourquoi d'abord parce qu'à
une exigence de résultats qui percute de
plein fouet l'exigence de patience
qu'impose de temps dans la lutte contre
la dette on en parle la réforme des
retraites la réindustrialisation mais
aussi la réforme d'un système éducatif
tout ça sont des chantiers que dont les
résultats se mesure à l'aune de près
d'une décennie au minimum et ça rentre
pas dans le quartier dans le calendrier
parlons politique qui rythmée par des
élections intermédiaires et puis surtout
depuis la mise en place du quinquennat
qui fait qu'on pense à sa réélection dès
le jour de sa prise de fonction et puis
la seconde rire
c'est qu'on gouverne gouverner
aujourd'hui dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est surtout de la gestion de crise et
donc du coup il faut réagir je vous
donne un chiffre depuis six ans on avait
eu une la moitié du temps en état
d'urgence c'était sécuritaire puissent
et sanitaires un jour un état d'urgence
voilà ça montre bien en tout cas dans
quel état d'esprit on est parce que
l'urgence commande la réactivité devient
la règle et puis du coup le temps de
service disponible se concentre sur
l'instant et non plus sur l'époque et
puis remises à plus tard du coup les
réformes parce qu'on peut pas tout faire
il faut le dire c'est vrai que pendant
que coville on peut pas tout faire
pendant le terrorisme on pouvait pas
tout faire et puis avant il y avait à
nicolas sarkozy pendant les crises des
dettes en europe on ne pouvait pas tout
faire voilà on est confronté à ça comme
on en sort comme en cent ans est-ce
qu'on peut changer le calendrier alors
je vais vous donner la réponse de
françois hollande qui s'en tirer par une
pirouette il est le quinquennat c'est
trop court mais deux septennats c'est
trop long
ensuite c'est à grand chose six ans mais
bien voilà moi là je pense
j'espère me tromper mais qu'on en
sortira pas parce que c'est devenu
culturel civilisationnel
notamment la révolution numérique nous a
fait accoucher d'une aire de l'instant
on est à l'ère du tout tout le temps
tout de suite que ce soit pour les
consommateurs que ce soit pour les
citoyens on veut tout tout le temps tout
de suite et donc ça je pense que ce sera
difficile d'en sortir c'est intéressant
cette idée du temps long françois ecalle
parce que vous parliez tout à l'heure de
de l'investissement et de la capacité à
juger de l'efficacité d'investissement
finalement c'est là dessus qu'on pourra
évaluer aussi le discours et les
annonces du président de la république
demain sauf que là il faut du temps dont
il faut dû l'entendre on en ait failli
le temps d'évaluation est un temps long
parce que il faut prendre le temps de
rassembler les données de les analyser
et donc en effet sept as et incompatible
avec le temps politique qui lui est
probablement de plus en plus courts et
une bonne gouvernance à jouer parce que
c'est là le grand problème et c'est ce
qu'il faudra surveiller demain avec
attention c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
financement de l'innovation en france
étaient éparpillés entre eux quatorze
bureaux je vais vous avez bpi france
bras armé financier de l'état vous avez
le secrétariat général au programme
d'investissements d'avenir qui qui est
là depuis dix ans vous avez bercy dans
différents bureaux enfin tout le monde a
son petit carnet de chèques et sa
tuyauterie mais qui ne forment pas un
ensemble cohérent est ce que françois
ecalle a tout à fait raison de souligner
c'est qu'il faut de l'est va lui à sion
à quoi sert le euro d'argent public
dépensés et ça ça manque cruellement
quel système on pourrait mettre en place
pour ça c'est à dire qu'on dit accord au
bout d'un an on évalue l'efficacité des
investissements nous donnant le lorient
est un modèle il fait rêver tout le
monde en france et en europe dont on
n'arrête pas de parler et qu'on n'arrive
pas à mettre en place c'est la darpa à
l'américaine labarda pour le côté
sanitaire ou la darpa qui est le côté
militaro défense qui est là où sont nés
ou
on a aidé les géants la tech en tout cas
à grandir c'est de l'argent public
fédéral américain beaucoup d'argent des
milliards et des milliards pour financer
la recherche militaire mais qui sert
aussi aux civils à côté et où des
investisseurs des des inventeurs des
innovateurs des génies comme elon musk
peuvent profiter de fond très élevé pour
se développer ses largesses et qu' on en
parle beaucoup c'est la recherche
publique qui sert aux civils et aux
marchés privés on en parle beaucoup en
france et même au niveau européen on a
du mal à le voir venir encore mais c'est
françois millet rapport de la cour des
comptes ils servent à ça
en partie quand même alors ils servent à
ça sauf que la cour des comptes n'a
aucun pouvoir par elle-même ce qui est
normal dans une société démocratique ce
sont les élus qui décident ce sont pas
les juges ou les experts de la cour des
comptes la question c'est que fait-on
des rapports de la cour des comptes quoi
alors on en fait alors qu aux tombereaux
quand on a un peu la foi l'espoir se dit
qu avec le temps tu ça finit par avoir
des effets s'il ya quand même des jets
pas le la france n'est pas exactement
dans la même situation qu'elle était il
ya 30 ans ceci dit moi j'ai l'impression
parfois d'écrire la même chose que ce
que j'écrivais parce qu'avant d'être à
la cour des comptes j'étais à bercy
j'écris la même chose que ce que
j'écrivais quand j'étais à bercy il ya
déjà trente ans donc oui c'est un petit
peu femmes
beaucoup il ya des choses qui se passent
mais c'est quand même un peu un peu
désespérant aussi par certains aspects
parce que je fais ce que j'ai à dire par
rapport à ce que dit et mathieu crise le
temps long et ce dans l'eau on dit c'est
contradictoire avec le rythme électorale
je ne crois pas je crois que celle
inverse je crois que le en période
électorale et on le sait et c'est
toujours un peu bizarre c'est le message
le plus prophétique qui va l'emporter le
récit c'est il faut que l'homme
politique porte un récit et on le sait
même même aux états unis où un sentiment
que ce sont des gens extrêmement
bien comment dirais-je et enfin matériel
on parle de tout de suite de changement
total chance société on parle de
l'amérique on va et il ya une contrainte
pour l'homme politique qui depoorter ici
qui lui qui est apprécié de ré un récit
prospectifs
vivent pas là une campagne sur un bidon
et même pas sur des promesses qu auquel
personne ne croit on gagne 1 sur un
projet qui est un projet à long terme
qui est prêt un projet un peu fictif
mais tout le monde accepte de
s'embarquer dans ce projet et d'aller
avec le politique et quand on n'a pas ça
eh bien on a un mal fou à gagner selon
n'ayant pas ce projet en plus de réussi
à proposer il a préféré ne pas s'y passe
est sûr c'est qu'une fois élu c'est là
où là les échéances électorales vient de
considérer
que vous avez envie de ne pas être battu
aux élections intermédiaires et donc
vous commencez à gérer j'avais l'instant
mais c'est en cela que ce plan va être
important aussi demain le récit c'est la
france industrielle c'est plus la start
up nation en
même temps il ne peut pas réconcilier
considère
2010 est effectivement sur la start up
est jeune et on est sur l'innovation il
faut être très clair mais c'est une
ovation au service de l'industrie
emmanuel macron a bien vu que cette idée
de start up nation n'avait pas vraiment
rencontré un écho colossales dans
l'opinion publique alors que l'industrie
ça parle aux gens et de renouer avec ce
récit industriels et soit ce qu'il va
beaucoup parler de souveraineté demain
c'est aussi s'adresser à l'électorat à
la fois d'arnaud montebourg et de marine
le pen qui parie beaucoup sur le déclin
de la france en matière industrielle
ça permet de montrer que le chef d'état
est à la manoeuvre pour renouveau de
l'industrie française mais qu il ya
effectivement c'est en cet enjeu de la
souveraineté on va on va faire un peut
lister les secteurs clés a priori de ce
plan france 2030 la filière hydrogène
les semi conducteurs on en parlait tout
à l'heure l'intelligence artificielle
les avions bas carbone et les mini
centrales nucléaires aussi qui alors
celle là on est dans un choix qui est
quand même très politique celui du
nucléaire et ça fait bondir c'est ce
matin sur france info je sais pas si
vous avez entendu via nick shadow le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts qui
était assez mesuré sur la sortie du
nucléaire en dix ans on peut prendre du
temps ça va être 2040 peut-être 2045
s'il faut je suis pragmatique il
répétait ça à longueur d'interviews mais
en revanche l'idée de d'installer ou de
construire des mini réacteur ça passe
pas on écoute on va donc économiser
l'énergie déployée les énergies et
progressivement on fermera les réacteurs
nucléaires quand ça se met jamais en
danger c'est qu en installer notre parc
nucléaire à peu près en 20 ans moi je
vois une sortie en 20 ans etc je suis un
pragmatique s'il faut mettre 50 plus on
mettra 50 plus on va pas construire où
on va pas mettre de l'argent aujourd'hui
dans des petits réacteurs qui de toute
façon ne seront disponibles que dans au
moins 20 ans dans au moins 20 ans quand
on aura gagné ou perdu ou perdu la
bataille du climat est ce que c'est un
marqueur de droite matthieu croissandeau
7 ce positionnement sur le nucléaire non
historique mon nom historiquement ça a
été danseur à droite mais géré le parti
communiste le parti socialiste a été
défenseur du nucléaire donc c'est un
marqueur de souveraineté c'est un
marqueur de souverainté c'est aussi en
ce moment c'est ça ça devient un sujet
d'actualité brûlant parce que les prix
de l'énergie et au loin comme il évolue
on voit bien que tout à coup le
nucléaire reprend des couleurs en tout
cas dans le discours politique et que ce
tout commence à avoir des explications
pour redire aux gens que ce qui nous
permet d'avoir une électricité qui
augmente point que chez nos voisins
parce qu'il faut lire aussi ça augmente
moins connus et décarbonées et dévoila
et que ça augmente moins qu'en allemagne
c'est à côté grâce à l'industrie
nucléaire mais qui ont pu émailler
décarbonés le débat qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des déchets voit ses c'est autre chose
mais
moi je comprends pas du tout la position
des écologistes sur ce sujet là parce
que si la priorité pour les années à
venir assez la lutte contre les
émissions de co2 c'est ça le problème
que tous les pays du monde s'entende a
considéré comme étant prioritaires les
centrales nucléaires n'émettent pas de
co2 alors que si vous construisez des
éoliennes ou vous installer des panneaux
solaires vous êtes obligé de mettre à
côté des centrales à gaz qui vont elles
émettre du co2 et les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires émettre du co2 parce
que vous êtes obligé de faire tourner
des centrales à gaz quand il ya pas de
vent on quand ya pas de soleil donc
c'est absurde de cette position si
l'inter sur
la question
bizarrement la question du climat à
faire repartir une uc les airs alors
qu'on y sembler après ce qui est arrivé
à fukushima que c'était fini et c'est
bizarrement à partir du climat d'aucune
question écologique a fait renaître le
nucléaire il n'empêche que la question
du nucléaire et ses dangers pause les
fukushima n'est pas non plus disparu
pour autant et
qousseir on va probablement présente
plus de danger que les centrales
nucléaires n'ont jamais se faire aider
entre deux mots je sais pour le coup
c'est un marqueur idéologique d'europe
écologie les verts parce que le
mouvement écologiste en france s'est
construit d'un direct sur les
antinucléaires mais même si nicolas
hulot au départ était plutôt favorable
n'est clair il a changé d'avis fayez
écologistes l'époque
j'en avais pas là pour faire un débat
autour de autour d'europe écologie les
verts mais il ya une autre problématique
qui pourrait se poser je sais pas ce que
vous serez d'accord avec moi demain
c'est l'étiquette de président des
riches le secrétaire général de la cfdt
laurent berger c'était ce dimanche sur
france inter alors il parlait de
effectivement des annonces d
investissement d du plan de relance
gouvernemental est annoncé par à paris m
il veut que les aides aux entreprises
soient conditionnées à des engagements
notamment en termes d'emploi en écoute
laurent verger de 30 milliards c'est
face aux enjeux qui sont là il faudra
que ce soit accompagné d'un vrai plan
d'évolution des compétences il faudra
qu'on puisse se dire que ça ça nécessite
qu'on accompagne à hauteur de femmes et
d'hommes les salariés et puis le dernier
point je vais vous dire sur ce plan
d'investissement c'est qu'à un moment
donné il faut aider économiquement va
falloir demander va falloir conditionner
ses aides publiques aux entreprises eh
bien ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
qu'ils aient des logiques de traiter
correctement leurs sous traitants de
créer de l'emploi décret d'activité à
fait le genre c'est vrai que l'exercice
pour le présent et public demain c'est
aussi de de faire comprendre qu'il ya
des enjeux sur l'emploi avec avec ce qui
va annoncer oui d'ailleurs une partie du
plan sera sur les compétences c'est ça
le grand sujet du moment c'est à dire
qu'il va falloir on assiste à une
accélération de l'histoire qui fait qu
il ya d énormément de secteurs qui vont
être distribués comme on dit en macro ni
par notamment partie
c'est un peu 2017 contre vos chose moi
en 2021
des secteurs qui vont être totalement
transformé par par le numérique certains
vont totalement disparaître et il y à
des millions d'actifs qu'on va devoir
reformer pour les orienter vers d'autres
secteurs ou même des actifs au sein de
certaines entreprises qui vont être sur
des postes qui vont disparaître et qu'il
faut informer pour aller vers
on aura certains ont beau jeu de dire ah
bah c'est encore des milliards pour
telle industrie tels sécurité parce que
sur les contreparties va forcément
arriver comme à chaque fois qu'on verse
des aides aux entreprises ont
aujourd'hui même le l'examen du budget a
commencé en séance publique à
l'assemblée nationale vous pouvez être
sûr qu'on aura qu on aura ce débat dans
l'hémicycle le sujet sur cette séquence
n'est pas tant celui de président des
riches inquiétait une séquence dont on
sort tout juste c'est-à-dire que pour la
présentation du budget le ministère des
finances notamment nous a pondu de beaux
graphiques pour nous expliquer que et
bien c'était les plus modestes et les
classes moyennes qui sur le quinquennat
étaient ceux qui avaient le bénéficier
le plus de hausse de pouvoir d'achat en
proportion c'est vrai c'est plutôt que 4
% pour les plus modestes et 2% pour les
plus aisés alors le problème c'est que
4% des revenus très modestes ça fait
quelques dizaines d'euros quand 2 % les
plus aisés ça fait plusieurs centaines
pour certains plusieurs milliers et
goreux en plein débat sur les prix de
l'énergie
avaient oui mais là des mesures ont été
prises seulement du chèque et
c'est exactement le problème c'est que
c'est une bataille très probablement
perdu d'avancé très compliqué de pour
emmanuel macron ce sera très compliqué
de cette de s'enlever cette étiquette de
président des riches je pense il fini je
voulais dire que cette idée qu'on entend
souvent dans le débat public de
conditionner les aides aux entreprises
par des engagements sur l'emploi en
pratique c'est impossible de mettre en
place supposons que vous disiez bomba
pour avoir des aides il faut que vous au
moins vous créer des emplois vous ne
perdiez pas des entreprises
informatiques aucun problème toute façon
spontanément elles ont créé plein donc
en amazonie garde aucun problème moi je
crée des emplois maintenant la
métallurgie la sidérurgie non on ne crée
pas d'emplois le problème c'est d'en
détruire le moins possible mais on en
détruit parce que les gains de
productivité le progrès technique fait
qu'il ya de moins en moins d'emplois
dans ce genre de secteurs alors si vous
êtes un bureaucrate intelligent vous
allez dire bon qu'à cela ne tienne je
vais avoir un objectif d'emploi
différents pour l'informatique la
sidérurgie les hôtels etc vous allez
construire une usine à gaz dans
lesquelles vous des objectifs différents
par branches d'activité mais même à
l'intérieur d'une branche d'activité à
l'intérieur de la sidérurgie dans
sidérurgie il ya des aciers spéciaux
pour le cad avec des entreprises qui
créent des emplois donc même si vous
faites donné un objectif spécifique à la
cdu rougis il ya des entreprises pour
lesquelles ça sera très facile et
d'autres lesquels ça sera impossible
vous n'y arriverez pas vous allez
construire des usa en faisant ça des
usines à gaz bureaucratiques qui ne
serviront à rien j'aurais terminé au rsa
peu près trois minutes pourra revenir à
une thématique un peu plus politique
matthieu croissandeau et françois bayrou
dans l'histoire mais oui françois bayrou
c'est ça qui
lui il a été nommé il ya un an il était
chargé de réfléchir ces grands chantiers
d'avenir c'est cette france de plus tard
je croque les cinq rapports cinq
rapports depuis un an et françois bayrou
paraît aujourd'hui plus occupés à la
cuisine interne de la majorité à faire
des dîners pour savoir quelle partie
centrale occupera la place en
jeu je taquine un peu mais c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas ce haut commissariat au
plan qu'on nous avait vendu comme
l'outil l'instrument qu'ils allaient
pousser la réflexion et les grands
chantiers une belle pour l'instant on
reste sur notre faim il pleut il pleut
il va jouer quel rôle dans la campagne
françois rôle très politique très
probablement il sera assez peu présent
sur la france de 2030 comme ça a été dit
il sera très présent dans la maison
commune par contre pour
à la fois contre le mouvement est placée
aussi ses troupes pour les législatives
quel grand sujet 2022 c'est ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas rien parce que la
question du rassemblement est
essentielle en ce moment en politique
mais c'est encore un pourvoi un atout
dans le jeu 2 du présent république
françois bayrou alors si effectivement
il parvient à
rassembler les troupes à éviter les
petites voix discordantes et a
montré encore une fois je parle de
récits que derrière ce président il y a
une certaine
il ya des gens il y a des espérances il
y a ighil porte un projet sur lequel il
y avait différentes générations les
générations plus anciennes les
générations nouvelles pourquoi pas est
ce que c'est en tous les cas c'est
l'enjeu actuel delà de ces deux
sélections qui ressemble incroyablement
aux élections de 2002 et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en 2002 ça a été ça a été le
résultat de cette incapacité que tout le
monde a u dessus ni est là et il semble
que c'est ce qui va se passer en 2000 en
2008 22 et donc ce n'est pas rien
d'arriver à créer une maison commune un
françois meyroune qui avait fait de la
dette la réduction a donné une entre hal
et qu'on entend
et puis en plus se rappeler puis frappé
il a fait des choses très incroyable à
l'époque ce qu'ils avaient dit que
l'immigration était une chance pour la
france et même une nécessité je crois
que c'est la seule voix que j'ai entendu
dire qu'il faudrait qu'on est un peu
plus d'immigrés en ce moment
c'est là peut-être contraint un peu de
modestie modestie merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat